die show ist eine stadt im kriegszustand
150 wurden komplett abgeriegelt
1967 das erste mal in amerika jeder was
das bedeutet dass man große
rassenunruhen die überall im land und in
detroit ganz besonders nochmal zwischen
der schwarzen bevölkerung und der in
ostberlin weißen polizei damals gab es
ein ereignis des damals jedenfalls
angeblichen aufzuklären war es geht um
vorfälle mutter muss eine mutter und
kein steigt in einem hotel
und am dienstagabend hatten wir schüsse
aus der richtung von algier
die polizei war da
das grabmal riesen schießerei
was dort passiert ist am ende waren
einige menschen tot aber es war
jedenfalls klar weil die polizei musste
klar sein aber irgendwie in dem
anschließenden gerichtsverfahren ließ es
sich wieder mal nicht beweisen schon mal
jemand erschossen
ich weiß nicht die polizei
sie kann als extrem nah an den leuten
dran sich immer ganz nahe bei den
abfällen fast schmerzhaften nähe
vom rauch über den bildern die sie nie
so stumpf werden lässt
kathryn bigelow ist ja eine große action
regisseurin zurückgedrückt im
kriegszustand die nimmt diesen alten
fall und zu zeigen hier kommt das ist
unsere geschichte und wir sind kein
stückchen weiter einerseits finde ich es
toll dass sie sich dieses themas annimmt
neue leute immer noch unsicher ob ich
das eigentlich legitim finden die welt
wieder tot
in amerika gab es ganz unterschiedliche
stimmen sie sich fragen darf sie das
weil sie weiß ist es gibt aber auch die
stimmen die sagen dass sie so grausam
was in diesem hotel passiert was tut sie
ihren darstellern
für mich seid ihr alle vergleiche wie
war das denn jetzt für diese jungen
schwarzen darsteller sich derartig
beleidigen demütigen schein hinrichten
zu lassen aber den wesentlichen einwand
gegen den fernseh ich woanders und das
ist dass der natur wieder der immer das
drehbuchschreiben großer sommerlust
eigentlich der hatten mit zeitzeugen
gesprochen der hat nicht überleben
gesprochen gibt es ja noch sind noch da
er hat also das was ich angeblich nicht
wirklich rekonstruieren lässt im
hinblick darauf ob eine schuld sich
feststellen
das hat der recherchiert und wäre das
nicht auch eigentlich ein super
dokumentarfilm geworden wenn willst du
nach hause
was also muss
[Musik]